[Music]
greetings Louis whatever it is you're
planning no you won't get away with it
well this time I think I do you see I've
attached LexCorp lasers to every
satellite in the sky if your puny news
organization attempts to notify anyone
even stitch the heat beam hot enough to
fry the ocean killing everything inside
fortunately Lex Corp industrial fish
farm products will be available for a
premium price it's over Lex sorry
Superman my plan is foolproof even with
you what you killed him
he was gonna hurt living things what
choice did I have plus it's totally fine
Christopher Nolan said it was cooler
this way that's not cooler you're
Superman a beacon of hope you're not a
you're not a monster like Lex for a
brooding dark knight like Batman even he
doesn't kill people it's your duty to
always find the other way to save the
people not just needed come on I
couldn't have been the only one bored by
this guy right Superman out